哇!今天台灣股市又大跌了
一度跌千點
最後跌大概五、六百點、五百多點
很多人想要知道台灣股市三大重點
第一個 結算健壯者嗎?
這一句話是我發明的哦
指責發明的哦
什麼台股得了不會跌的病
這都是我發明的哦
很多人拿去引用沒有關係
可是我要重生一次
這是我的專利
結算健壯者
會不會這一次轉折是往上還是往下
因為今天結算日嗎?
最新的期貨
衛平山的多單還是空單
是怎麼一回事
應該是空單啦 怎麼一回事
台股萬點目標不變嗎
今天這種人要跟大家講
第二個 再卷直率標深
這個是非常專業的
今天頭版新聞才有人講到
講了以後你能看到很多分醫師
很多財經網友在講
昨天之前我就已經在重生這個東西了
那會不會進到海嘯重演
因為20年來一個新高
上次就是賽卷執行率應該說利率的飆升
戳破這一切
那會不會 AI 泡沫戳破
這很重要
第二個 第三個 我今天反逆勢加碼這檔股票
那這代表 AI 沒有泡沫嗎
我買的是不是 AI 的股票
今天所有的秘密我一次講得夠
大家好 我是莫鴻投過的投賬
郭總的醫師
今天剛好主持人請假 沒有關係
那哲哲我今天來跟大家講
來講一個台股的秘密
為什麼都台股秘密 我們來看一下
來看一下
今天台灣股市跌589點
怎麼看 其實我一直要講 結算鍵轉折
今天你們冷靜一下好不好
台灣股市漲了7000點 不可能每天漲
那你會不會打第二隻腳
但你不能說戰爭船第二隻腳
第二隻腳定義我覺得至少要回到許多4萬2
打到4萬2在這邊
雖然有這殘短角啦
我覺得真的更嚴厲一點是應該
這回到四萬點
我覺得這回到四萬點其實蠻低的
為什麼蠻低?我先跟大家講來
第一個我們來看一下
台灣有點被廢半給拖累
我們請大家請那個威漢來給我看一下
今年廢半指數的斬跌幅
我們來看今年廢半指數斬跌幅
還有那個廢半
那斯達克還有那個SNP500 日本韓國 台灣股市這6個
請他告訴我書資就好 你要問AI也可以
請我要馬上告訴我 為什麼要請他做這個圖
我告訴你就是今年美國股市並沒有上漲很多
台灣股市大概上漲53% 從年初到現在
非辦指數沒有 如果印象沒出來20%而已
那斯達克20% 好不好 很簡單
因為我說我有買這種國外的ETF
或者0062這種是不是納斯拉克ETF
所以算一下報酬率大概就知道了
好不好,十幾%會一樣
頂多十幾%
所以這些...那為什麼?十幾%要幹嘛?
我想重點
美國股市不太存在有一個崩盤的空間
因為今年它展得還真的不多
美國股市沒有存在崩盤空間,因為今年展不多,整個邏輯怪怪的,因為展不多,所以就一定不會崩嗎?
當然景氣崩盤也會崩,只是就一個中台型來看的話,你每年大概是展120%,今年真的展不多啦,好不好?
這幾年來長更多,前幾年長更多,到二、三十%
所以納斯拉克今年長不多,非辦也差不多
所以理論上這兩個指數跟台灣相關系數最重要的兩個股市
基本上不破底,台灣股市破底的機率就不會大幅度增加
這我給你獨家祕密,我想趕快給我數字,我跟大家講
所以我們今天來今天點點名,因為網友們每次都很現實
大跌倒出來想到我 啊對 接萬計的
今天我剛好今天是情人節
不過我順帶來一個禮物
怎麼拿下
啊愛心
好啦 人笑話
其實大家有情人
有情人 忠誠眷屬
這剛好符合史詞
而且很多人說我遇到前面
我是不是說過
我說你發現到
不論是你要跟男生分手
還是男生要跟女生分手
人家以前會報復你
到最後要報復你不論成性也好
九妹的女朋友也好
會報復你怎麼樣
心委屈的 心真的很委屈
錢也委屈的
你不能用錢跟心的委屈
你讓人家人才兩死
那你就很容易變成要報復
所以有時候錢能解決很多的事情
錢不一定讓你一定幸福沒滿
但沒有錢會很容易讓你非常不開心
所以祝大家有錢人
友情人、中情建築、愛心跟插票
一線之隔
記得這是人生後黑血
好不好 我會送大家一個花
花在哪裡?
卡住了 花在這邊
好不好 爛哏
愛你們啦
責愛你們好不好
別的那些哲哲寶貝
這我都害羞了 好不好 看一下
來來來
還有人說哲哲
你那個喜歡男生女生
我告訴大家 只要你們喜歡我 你們愛我 我都愛你們 好不好
這個有點18禁喔
我是不太 我是不太幫人家煮麵
所以很多人說 哇 我一定很溫柔
跟別人比 不要亂講
可是我很大方 我很大方
我是屬於那種 就是譬如說你去名牌店
譬如說去Dio 去哪邊 可能本來要買我的
對家人、對所愛的人可能自己本來要買
可能自己都沒有買
然後可能別人身上花個幾十萬
我就是這種人
買一買我也不想買
所以還算大班了 應該算大班了
好不好
來 還是不車園的
也不知道自我介紹
來
其實我覺得其實哲哲的私生活不重要
重點是投資的品德
同資的品性你們可以高規格要求我
這個我覺得沒問題
這個我經得起挑戰
短期美在可以買嗎?
美在同同是垃圾
只有我留著垃圾
好不好?
這把被今天剪的國具好嗎?
華班店我以為有點像
買到華班店長有點多
國具我今天就是剪的國具
怎麼剪的大家可以講
好不好?
這把被
不好意思
很有愛又大煩謝謝你們
好不好?
這跟大家講
半夜四點報股票,去年不會要什麼東西
來來,郝韻谷最近有機會,郝韻谷最近很猛
你看我不要去講那些,你看到一些老頭故意
現在郝韻谷強了,開始就說我郝韻谷了
他已經忘記你的AI股了,他已經忘記你的GT了
他忘記你的南亞科,忘記你的群年,忘記你的爬班店
萬計你的老AI管達 萬計你的細管子、CPO
萬計你的被動元件 就突然有航運股了
又不是每個人都一來一去的
所以我覺得不要做這種事情
航運股我一看 但是有些我現在還是住在AI
航運股不會長太多 只有AI股才是完到
這跟大家講 折折好沛琴的節快樂
謝謝你們每個教寶貝 好不好
怎麼看目前的惠利驅使
慕尼文利坦台幣有回升了 也回升了
我們今天我們要講很多總經典 慢慢講好不好
我講到你們會覺得 要不是我
我們先講說美在這個垃圾
要不是我當分析師 我真是少賺一億啊 我騙你
我是說真的啦 你們都知道 我在講一件事
我在1萬7的時候 我本來要出掉
是因為有人叫我不要 大家有人罵我
我就沒有出了
大家都知道
我是今年買台灣50在這邊買對不對
沒錯吧
大印象去年買台灣50在這邊
去年買台灣50在這邊
沒有錯這邊
你們看錯沒
看錯
今年台灣50在這邊
去年台灣50在這邊
沒有看錯這邊
這邊
不清楚
直接看 現在4萬4
去年台灣50買這邊
什麼時候買這邊
18000多啦
這個
網路上都有消息都有報道
那時候我就想要把美
那時候為什麼是用湊錢去買台灣50
因為那時候美在沒有賣掉
被卡住了
是不是 你看那時候如果放到現在台灣50
1.7億美在賣掉
換台灣50不長很多
不會是現在這樣子
虧錢情況之下 我兩隻夾起來差不多
因為我一次賺1500萬 現在就是虧錢棒子
所以我說美債就不要買了 好不好
美債目前除非你資金就是一億以上
你要部分的飯 為什麼說美債是個垃圾
我罵自己可以罵 不是罵大家
我還持有這個垃圾 你看美債規模
2027年看到 從9點多債看到
你看到現在2026年看到
我們看這邊,這是2020年,這每一點都是一年一年,你看
你看哦
像38.51到39,你看
今年,你看前幾年才
2020年才23兆,現在已經38兆
2020年才多少
無限QE那一年才23兆左右,有沒有
從23兆到27兆
現在38兆了,去年38兆
現在要突破40兆了,錢幾年才31兆而已
那你叫這什麼時候?
2022年,AR含錢的時候,現在又增加10兆了
增加10兆
你看,2007年的時候金融海峽才10兆的規模
現在已經變40兆了,所以錢越來越不值錢
所以我才說傻瓜才把錢放在銀行,為什麼?銀行定存永遠給你定存利率1.2%啊,可是你看現在30年期關在值利率你看多高了,是不是?在這邊你自己看,來來來,到5.33啊,銀行就拿你的錢對不對?
哇,你買1億,你把1億的錢放在銀行,傻瓜啦
定存2%啦,不到啦,不到啊
去買美國公債啦
5%以上啦
人家什麼都沒做就賺你300萬啦
最傻的把錢放在銀行
而且從發債規模你看2007年,那時候金融海峽20年前而已
不到10兆,現在沒有幾年的時間就增加10兆美金
這代表什麼意思?發債郭文貓越來越快,代表政府的營商票,
代表錢越來越不值錢,錢越來越不值錢,各位!
所以這是資本主義的必然趨勢,這也是,因為很多人不懂歷史,
所有的高層管理階層就是逼大家不斷的往前進,不斷的工作,
工作的兩個好處,第一個讓自己頭腦健康、身體健康
這是我一直秉信的,你們不認同沒關係
可是第二個你也不得不工作,因為錢會越來越薄
如果錢越來越肥,通縮,不好意思那沒有人要工作
你懂這個陰謀論,這真的是合理的陰謀論
資本主義市場就是一直不斷的通膨,把你的錢給吃掉
能不能把你的錢給吃掉?
所以你要別錢給吃掉,你就要像鐵銅裡面的老鼠,
你要跑得更快,最好投資是股市,
要聽懂我這句話,聽懂這句話,
而且不要愛啊,這世界不公平,
不要去怨恬有人,我就先講了,
我都很多人講AA制AA制,
我說哪個美女的追求者會給她AA制,
不會啊 因為知道別的競爭者一定是花錢在他身上
難能可苦為難難能 沒辦法
你不AA字 你要跟他勾大群 跟他克服各的
不好意思 美女不理你
我要找個理想對象 不好意思 這個不存在
那可能他個性溫柔很好 但是他各方面條件都非常好
很難 你懂不懂
很多人都理想主義者 這世界上沒有一個完美的理想主義
你什麼都不要計較 你反而知道比較多
來 有時候講講愛情 有時候講講股市
這個東西要借邏輯 好不好
每載子力那麼高 你看 今年以來30年起公佔
因為規模越滾越大 拉起來
42 BP 就是大概就是一個百分點
0.01 增加0.42% 30年起美國公佔
2007年以來的新高
我們來看一下
5年期公債也增加很多啦
10年期公債也增加很多好不好
就比例而言10年期公債增加比較快
因為同樣都是大概52Bp
大概就是0.52%
就是大概0.5%左右
倍子比較小的
基準比較小的是不是增加比較多
等等
這邊有比較枯燥沒關係
我快速跟大家講好不好
你去看一下在昨天之前有沒有跟你講
說美在常常之力率飆升
有沒有人跟你講這個
昨天有沒有人跟你講說
30年的美在飆升的利率創25年新高
你只要講這件事情
來我們看一下公安時報的頭版
你相信我你看了所有財經管好開始會講這個東西
有本事就早點講啊
各位
為什麼我最早講
因為我是美在垃圾的專家
我1.71
像0098A 你知道為什麼
納克賣掉只剩一張
一張要觀察一下 你有美在
你有持股就算剩一張你就會觀察他
所以我對美在之利利我特別敏感
不過我跟大家講我是覺得
人生開心就好
真的人生開心
雖然嘴巴唸唸唸我完全不後悔
對不起 哲哲剛好有個不專業的地方
謝謝威漢有跟我做這個東西
我說錯了
對不起 我剛剛一段話說錯
納斯達克只有33%
我是買納斯達克的ETF
沒錯吧
可是廢半有69%
可是納斯達克不太存在有暴跌的空間
你知道嗎
沒錯吧
美股也沒有
所以我剛才講一半對
美股大部分的美股沒有存在暴跌的空間
請威漢把這張圖趕快簡化
叫AI做一下,天懂嗎?
那美股裡面的納斯達克長很多
但美股裡面的廢半指數跟S&P500指數
長不多,OK嗎?
那通常而言,台灣股市是納斯達克指數的漲幅
再加廢半指數的漲幅的中間指跡下來
中間值大概是現在差不多82差不多
台灣股市在漲54差不多差不多
真的 這個我是獨家跟你講的
台灣股市的漲幅是費半
比如說費半我今天漲6%
然後我納斯達哥漲2%是6加28
8出又是4%
所以台灣股市應該要漲個4%
這樣能不能懂understand
有沒有分析師跟你講這些
沒有 你不要看著真美
那個你講的是愛情的笑話
什麼愛情的哏
沒有 我們真的厲害是頭腦好不好
真的啦,我跟你講,你都網紅看起來很專業
那些都是人家研究員給他資料,腦袋裡面
裡面懂不懂?
你懂不懂?
欸,團團表演你要搞清楚喔
有些人是寫文章,寫文章我會先查AI資料
可以了,可是你看我都看著你眼睛講
有些人是錄音
欸沒有,我看著眼睛講,你怎麼知道他們都搞
一堆搞念子啊
因為我都在我腦海裡啊 你們問我問題我直接回答
各位寶貝們 我說的沒錯吧
你要知道我跟別人差別
然後趕快開放直播問你們 問我 你懂不懂
美在這個東西 你看
不是美在 這直立的東西這幾天一定有很多人講
頭版新聞就這個
關於直播頭版新聞
那今天開始有很多網紅在講的
為什麼不像我提早講
這的確是一個大問題
我一直跟大家講
今年我最怕什麼
我不怕AI泡沫
我只怕,我只怕直率問題,我只怕深洗問題,有沒有講
深洗不就載進直率會比較高了嗎?是不是
我只怕深洗,因為2022年就從18000-120002
就是一直深洗一直深洗一直深洗
為什麼?深洗很簡單,你深洗完以後
我用一個簡單,我這樣可以用折線率的功夫
比較專業的說法是折線率,我怕你聽不懂
我用一個最簡單的東西好了
如果我台灣股市的平均值率百人3%對不對
我公債值率率也3%
可是我台灣因為台灣股票一直漲
值率會下滑變2%
台灣股市值率變2%
假設
可是我公債值率從3%變6%
你資金會不會去買公債
會嘛 6%那股市2%
雖然股市有成長性
可是多少有些資金會來
來到債市
所以資金會吸到這邊去
不會細到再次,就是這樣子崩盤
原本都3%,可是股市因為漲值率變2%,值率嘛
就是我100萬,我可以賺2%
OK嗎?好,先不管成長性,管他的鼓勵
然後公債,因為一直印鈔票
印鈔票以後怎麼樣?我要吸引你高利率
你知道嗎?以前都這樣子啊,好不好
以前是老鼠會都這樣子 哇 給你高利率變6%
當然美國債券不會是老鼠會 絕對不會倒
變6%
美國債券變6% 你會不會資金從股市移過去
一個2% 6% 差很多 越差越多
這邊7% 這邊8% 等我意思吧
資金的吸引來吸引去
昨天只有我講這一個
我說30年不要送美債資金 穿25年新高
應該不是20年 應該說25年性高
標準率
5.216
一個是標準率 一個是利率
沒關係 這個有點
我講太多 我怕你們聽不懂 好不好
反正我講過子力問題
來 阿巴貝茨是6.4 有沒有呢
是不是
那現在很難用 因為AI的關係你能不懂
AI我缺錢 我公司付得起6% 這是7%
所以6% 7%我來像這樣子
沒有分析是跟你講這麼結論
就是我因為AI投資的關係
你們說我現金有問題
好 我去借錢
我借錢我一定要高利貸
是不是因為越借越多
我借100萬的利率跟1000萬的利率一定不一樣
借那麼多你一定要借那麼多
那你利率要給我多一點
我昨天講這段 有想這一段對不對
好 AI利率越借越多
然後他的公司債的利率是不是會飆高
條件一定要標高你才會借我
越標越高
標到6%以上
美在直立
這時候畫面給我
AI的公司在
AI公司就是阿巴貝斯Google
他們的公司在越標越高
變6.4%
甚至7%以上
6%至7%
那我還有我
那是不是資金會往AI走
往AI走沒錯吧
那這時候我美國在線怎麼辦
我也缺錢
前幾年才30兆 現在快40兆了
他說我也學姐怎麼辦
我前輩你洗手了
然後我也要飆高
我一起飆高音是不是
差一下小安
我要飆高音
是不是 要飆高音
大家飆高囉
公債飆售率要飆高
你看我前輩
AI公司搶走了
美國政府要發行美國公債
我也要飆高
我有標高營從4% 四%多變5%
被AI的公司再給搶走
美國的公債也要標高
美國的公債標高 那是股市又遭殃
一個循環 昨天有沒有跟人家講
這些 有 OK嗎
發債規模的 投資行動日子
好不好 零點四照是還好啦 但也不小
你有沒有看到
你要看一件事 去年才1.1兆
有沒有看到 現在一下子增加0.4兆
增加4000億美金
連增36%很誇張
對不對 我昨天講這一段
是不是 好
來 關鍵數據有沒有看到
2007年有沒有看到
為什麼 可是我今天標題很手動
我這個年紀很小
歷史會重演
讓我在這邊可以賣個關子
要不要先休息一下
這段有點複雜
會不會太難?太難我不要講了
來看一下
有聽到嗎?有聽到
不要高音
不然無聊
我怕太複雜的時候我今天
唯一買進那檔股票
國巨我們念一下
那個11報念一下
8月19號禮拜三今天簡訊
請買進2327國巨掛在570元買進
已經買進的不用再買
國慶也買了有什麼呢?像576啊,所以買得漂亮
我覺得很難回到500元以下,因為住宿的第二隻腳
理論上不存在,不存在的腳
OK嗎?不太會破題,OK
而且很多你看6173新商店,暫停版的各位
很多背段元件是長2492,華興科怎麼樣?是不是還是長了?
現在大部分很多敢拉股票,你忘記了,處置跟以前差很多了
本來20分鐘一次處置最多,現在變兩分鐘一次處置了,差很多
這力多還會持續發酵
我們剛才講的為什麼歷史不會重演來看?
它現在,長短在力率差沒有很多
你懂不懂?所以現在問題是美國,它30年期每再直立有沒有看到?
它不太一樣,那個30年期每再直立,它是我要升起,我要升起,
你覺得你看到兩個費的利率有沒有看到?
現在費的利率大概差不多3.75左右,跟美國公債利率不一樣,
來一件事,紅色是30年起美在紫綠,藍色是費的利率,
我這樣圖表很好,我做得很好,歷史為什麼不會重演,
真正會戳破,我跟你講,真正會戳破的話,我問的是費的利率,
不是美在紫利率,可是因為現在有人看到陰影就打槍,
看到黑影就設,很多網紅、很多華爾街的分機師
那現在台灣有些網紅,我曾經分
網紅,其實台灣的網紅有些總經鏈
比台灣的一些本土分機師還厚實,我得要說
他們反而注重總經鏈,我得要說
可是最厲害的總經鏈是我
來,我看他們的結論這樣子
因為他們會出破泡沫的
永遠都是廢的生息
這記者一件事,會出破真正泡沫
網路泡沫也如此
2008年金融海嘯也如此
都是做個籌碼面去戳破
拜託你把這一段記起來
100倍一定要記起來
所以那時候他們覺得戳破2007年的反力產泡沫
到2008年金融海嘯就是因為美在直率很高
慘了 我們現在的直率比2007年的直率還高
是不是美在直率
錯了 為什麼錯了
那是因為我以前說如果費的利率在5.25,你每在值的利率你能比它低嗎?
我的基準就在這邊了,我發行公債利率當然比它高一點,
但是我的基準就在這邊了,我費的利率,現在費的利率像美國央行一樣,
台灣央行一樣,廢者就像台灣的央行
我基層率在這邊,我要發債真的比他更高
沒錯吧,我這個利率就在這邊
結果5.5,我一定比他高
聽主邏輯
所以那時候戳破他,泡沫是廢者利率
因為那時候廢者利率就那麼高了,2017年
所以美在直率也那麼高
可是現在美債值利率5.31,看起來很高,但實際上費的利率這麼低,
FVDA利率這麼低,像台灣央行的美國央行,
講美國央行,戰獎金會比較聽懂,利率這麼低。
但以前是因為你不能用美債質疑來看,真正戳破破墨的是非的利率。
那為什麼現在誤差那麼大?
因為發債規模越來越大,還有AI,就像AI吸走的美債資金,
你知道嗎?害他不得不提高
你知道嗎?多少會影響一點點
但真正戳破泡沫是費得利率
那懂不懂?
以前為什麼費得利率那麼高?
因為我原本費
以前為什麼沒在利率那麼高?
因為我費得利率就那麼高
所以我不得不高
那現在為什麼費得利率這麼低?
沒在利率那麼高
因為發債規模越來越高了
理論上不會泡沫
可是一定會吸收一些資金
還是會有一些流動性的問題
你知道嗎?
菇子還會下修,OK嗎?
OK嗎?有些錢還是會借錢來?
我又借錢,不好意思
你要我借你錢,結果拜託一點可不可以4%利率
我賺4%利率,不如去買美國公債
所以借錢會有問題,還是有問題
只是不會像費得率到5%的時候或是全面性的
這邊有點專業了,我就不講太多了,我怕你們聽不懂
你們看一下,想看你自己看,這真的很專業的
可是這個籌碼面的確是個問題
我們看他們的核心
還有這個就是講的利率如何壓縮 AI 股子
為什麼很簡單,就是我利率上升,我折現
就怎麼樣?我現在駕駛責限率就會變低
講這個太複雜了,我不管你們不要聽了
反正就是一個東西可以到5%,我借錢可以到5%了
股票市場就沒那麼漂亮了,就這樣子
所以錢會完再試走
OK,知道嗎?知道我邏輯
太專業,我怕你們聽不懂
OK嗎?好不好?每次保本,你真的保本而已
好不好
那不然你再怎麼樣還是比
不然我跟你講
每再也不能說是垃圾
那定存還是垃圾 我想起來
OK嗎
OK
好不好 明年會轉成像這樣
很難講這個要不要持續發酵
好不好
請問我把紅海換成華藩店你會推薦嗎
我覺得不錯
但是因為你就賭一把
可是華藩店的問題就是長很多
你懂不懂這時候
華藩店長很多 你懂嗎
其實我還是蠻看好他的
我覺得如果到150以下我會真的認真
150以下我買的機率很高
不代表現在不買 好不好
就決定你勝負的成本 你記得這件事
決定你勝負的成本
為什麼現在還講到那麼大聲
台灣50會賺一千多萬
為什麼現在講到那麼大聲
因為台灣50賺一千多萬 你懂嗎
這就決定我的勝負 我可以讓
來 定時還是垃圾 真的
好不好 你要想一件事
當美國美在規模越來越大的時候
為什麼越來越大
因為錢滾錢
錢滾錢
你知道嗎
當你有一兆的時候
同樣每年漲10%
你有一兆的時候漲10%
有10兆的時候漲10%
哪個漲比較快
一定10兆嘛
對不對
現在規模已經要40兆美金了
你懂不懂
請問一下利率高是刻意安排的揚某
美國富豪們持續產品賺高利息的
不是,我不能這樣講
應該說這個你把我講錯了
資本主義的市場
或整個市場就是這樣子
它讓人們持續的工作
因為人們都不工作怎麼辦
現在不是機器人都發生
那這社會就產品人就產了
資產就不會流動了
所以最好的方式就是一直通膨
但太高通膨也不好
所以沒有人喜歡很高通膨
OK嗎?來來來
我想把三張裝美金換成國巨好嗎?
不是會員一直問會員的問題
我不會理你們
我們來看一下
裝美金也沒什麼不好
這美金這邊也可以再買
真的太誇張了
其實都跌很兇
台灣股市最近前一波大戶受傷太嚴重了
他們現在為什麼
你知道為什麼很多人喜歡想第二隻腳
因為股市很少 V1 轉
尤其他人會兇
所以很多人喜歡講
第二隻腳會不會第二隻腳會?
那會不會第二支角
當然有機會你看現在股票第二支角
因為它反彈的弱
現在這麼反彈那麼弱的我確定拉回都可以買
只能會破底
我覺得基地很低
我剛已經講過了美國股市漲不多
所以不要想那麼多好不好
台灣股市很猛
之前是韓國股市贏我們賺了890%
你看這些都用AI做就好
AI查出資料,AI做圖,你看
前三名第一份是費辦
韓國,韓國本來長到80%-90%還是長100%
韓國股市也修正很嚴重
然後納斯達哥跟SNP500也沒有漲很多
既然他們沒有漲很多
那你就要去想想看,沒有漲很多
他們其實破底的機率
跌到一年,跌到說0%
很難
我今天如果我展100% 我韓國股市我展100%
我修正一半 我跌50%是很正常
我今天納斯拉克只展13% 你不要想太多好不好
基本上我覺得美國股市不存在泡沫空間
目前為止
AI真的是差很多 好不好 拜託一下 正常很多
想要請問你昨天提的群聯有沒有機會
有啦 有機會啦 我選低機器的慢慢轉
是不是 你看群聯今天為什麼收紅K
你跟他去問為什麼今天呢
為什麼2408
問南亞科今天點的熊
我們請問 剛才海力士好像疊死
好像我剛有新聞消息出來
問一下那個三星海力士的走勢圖
我們請一下那個危害人家好不好
來啦 2408
2408南亞科好不好
我們先3點14分 我們先休息一下好不好
先中產休息一下 我給你更多祕密
好不好 喝個水 休息一下滿懷
我們剛才看那個之前的預告
廣告 中間廣告 可能已經減掉了 沒關係
可是你有看到的人也看到
以前1萬3而已有沒有 2020年1萬3
以前12682歷史天閒 沒有
現在討論是不是5萬點
錢就是一直越來越薄
可是股市是Count on more
什麼叫股市可以Count on more
就是我每年我被我100萬塊
實際上我會變97萬
我每年3%被TOMO吃掉 3%到4%
實際上你的購買力道只能變97萬
你只買97萬東西
變了嘛
可是你的投資股票100萬很容易變120萬
在看通膨
扣掉通膨後你還是可以賺個10萬 20萬
懂不懂
那台灣的房地產現在不成看通膨了
因為已經少實話了
很多人現在就等著爸爸來繼承
那怎麼辦
除非你有乾性需求
你懂不懂
我就是要買房子
自己住開心
我就是要開公司
自己住可以缺比較好
自己買比較好
不然不要買
台灣版立場應該已經注定了就是崩壞的開始
好不好
來 哲月月年輕 謝謝大家
所以我就說現在要讓大家開心一點
你說月月年輕也是要維持很多
年輕有兩種意思是做醫美
一種是心靈上
做醫美你心情上不好還是看得出來很累你知道嗎
其實有些真的
我一樣看有些年輕女生都整過頭
其實如果有看過
我很厲害
我看得出來一個女生是鼻子
B字枕還是嘴巴打到小丑女的嘴巴
我看出來我對美感很厲害
整過頭都不太行
這車遠的 為什麼要講這個
好啦 來來來
這整體不好搬歪了
好 來啊
廣告那邊腳解釋意義嗎 不是喔 不是喔
一一穿衣服很保守喔
依效非常保守
關女生
韓國拉拉很多
來來 哲哲越南無數
經濟可能是最帥氣的哲哲經濟可以報
很多人講我看一下
在朝底一次 讓韓國人知道我厲害
不要啦 我每次買第一乾什麼
我不要不要不要
幹嘛在朝底 我不在講
又不是在跌破4萬點
跌破4萬點你只問我好不好
基本上不會跌破4萬點
剛剛有人說金居是
金居
像我帥氣
其實我跟你講
你不覺得這個股票10個不要
你有沒有犯大
你把它撤出你不覺得有點像國劇嗎
你不覺得像中美金嗎
都是要打第二隻腳
趕快買
之前你不敢買
這邊買是漂亮
這邊買真的漂亮
你相信我好不好
金居我覺得還是有機會
但是我覺得他本來比有點過高
國劇715均價
最近有沒有可能解套
有機會
接應你這邊 如果你是我會演 我會說500多再買
台子長的 明天要V轉了嗎?
我們看到台子長多少?
為什麼沒動?3.18分了
我們看一下
有有有 長140點
140點你就要長了
我跟你講 你沒有感覺好不好
0.5%才有感覺 1%算正常
所以你指400多點算正常好不好
400 這樣現在是4萬4千
來看一下 加你們的數字好不好 來
這個很簡單 因為他們每個人數學不一定一樣
像台灣股市是44719
沒有很簡單的數學 來
這個有些事情會想要轉台
4479% 1% 對不對
去掉後面 你就把去掉後面的尾數
後面把它去掉
你要400
447.1%
1%才叫做波動 稍微有波動的感覺
懂了嗎?
其實也不是台灣股市跌1000多點 還要3%
好 那你真的要有像樣的波動
一點點像波動 0.5%出於2
447出於2 223.5
那223.5才0.5%
所以這個叫你減斷數學
以後去掉尾數兩個 其實說一個正常波動
稍微有一點點波動 再出於2
223 數算法 每次看就知道這個
到底政府高不高 等等
OK嗎?現在139 現在139點
不多啦 你看我今天教很多大家數學
我太無聊了 我太無聊了 不要講那麼多
太專業不好 我一直在講一件事
我覺得我是蠻自己自豪的事
你們是直接問我 我都直接講
你不論你是看到人家是用
我不是要攻擊人家 我有可能專業
可是你說廣播也好 寫文章也好
哪一個像我這樣直播 你當然先問我
我可以講很多東西
而且我很多資訊都是比華爾街領先
你真的是外行看得到內行看不到
我是跟你說真的 好不好
OK嗎 我們靠同腦啦 真的啦 好不好
同腦重要 所以這個環境在之前那時候
台灣股市最大問題就是生息被搶走資金
現在公債持率有點高 危險
如果連費的利率也提高了 那就很危險
根本不懂 OK嗎
可是股市就在半信半應中成長
股市在半信半應中成長 OK嗎
拉回答爹自小趕快買好不好
下半年我要五萬點
五萬點我講的是至少
我認為至少 投資者進行的時候
本資料進攻場考沒有一定
我們是合法分析師 OK嗎
來 只是我看法是覺得蠻有機會的
管達 管達怎麼看 管達就是線情不錯
其實我是覺得紅瀾木我們奇妙 不應該這樣疊
神經給我這樣疊真的是很不給面子
代表這CEO不行
CEO這個講話要爽動一點
你沒學到市場上的講話
當CEO要做很多事要為行銷
那我們來看一下這成員
5483中美金一樣,黃金金怎麼看?
黃金金金金的昨天快斬停,今天一下快跌停,神經病
就跟精彩一樣,前天跌停,昨天給你斬停
前天跌停,昨天給你一度拉拉斬停
今天又給你殺下去,神經病
但是部分是國際股市關係,所以現在股票不追高
再點一次,現在股票不追高,相反拉回買金
拉回買金做加差
你跟女公用國際700多塊,奇怪,你房地又怎麼買
你房高到600多元,你就可以先走了,你來回住,起攤就好了
有1200的,很多人說我1200的過去,就不回來啦
我是不好意思跟你講啦,你沒有房地攤平你就不回來啦
不是那不是每一檔股票都可以房地攤平,我就國際可以房地攤平
所以你的股票的套價要高檔,你什麼都不能動
那股市真的不適合你
聽懂嗎?
你第一檔的時候你該加碼要加碼,但同學說什麼嗎?
該加碼加碼好不好
這跟大家講
我們來看一下
這是凡軒
今天聊天嗎
親人節聊天
聊一下指責的東西
有時候還是要講一個很重要的東西
大家好可能不知道為什麼我說同業
也之前我們去年不是同業攻擊我
一個星星講得很誇張
講得好像跟主力配合一樣
然後還有才調動爭氣大隊
去政交所去函
幸好我完全沒有任何跟主力配合即將
他查所有的同時間有沒有什麼人頭帳戶
我完全沒有
千劫比不起數更證明我的清白
至少兩個警察官
千劫
我說沒有 我問他為什麼我這麼生氣
因為我真的覺得很生氣
有時候你知道 我終於知道為什麼
有時候有些人 有些受害者
在法院的時候 到做不去法院
我每次開一支庭
我都要想像他們那時候什麼污賴我的
之前還講到說 哇 什麼出生什麼地下期貨
我之前的公司
之前的公司的某些人員涉及這個事情
代表我有嗎 還寫得很清楚
哇 在什麼 什麼什麼散書案件幾號幾號
一看 那裡面根本就沒有我
那個彰性分析師敢這樣寫
完全就是污賴我
該付出代價都是要付出代價
該付出代價都要代價
我買個美債我都不在乎少賺幾千萬幾億
我花多少的綠織費我真的不在乎
我進到同業不要做這種事情
你根本不知道折扣一例多少
為什麼我講一講
因為有時候想到很生氣
有時候我說真的我甚至燃燒我生命
那你明天有些同業在網路上
啊 折扣什麼時候他要虧錢
我從來沒有說過我一定讓人家賺錢
可是我可以跟你講我是最努力的分析師
真的最努力的分析師 我跟大家講的
所以我已經是法院已經逐漸的證明很多清白了
我是要告訴大家 真的真的
我講一下 先幫我摸一下
好 因為今天情人節 我就想講一件事情
我最愛的情人就是我的工作 就是你們
就是你們 真的真的 我就沒有工作
我覺得很無聊 真的我覺得滿好玩
但是寒情這回答你就買 你們真的很幸福
有AI這樣的東西 可是我告訴你
我告訴你,這次信服也是不信
因為之後我有很多人失業
好不好
我有很多人失業,我跟大家講
好不好,這次從滿面的麻煩
這enthopic他 IPO
IPO overuse 吸收資金
也是好玩的地方
可是我覺得會不斷不斷有一些東西
你看一下美國一開始已經有什麼
哇,今天美國已經模仿中國
因為中國有時候
不得不承認中國科技有時候有點領先美國
像無人機這一塊也是很恐怖
美國現在也是模仿它
以前Uber,UberEase
用無人機運送UberEase
中國先用,在美國用
像機器人戰鬥、機器人格鬥比賽美國開始也有
很恐怖啊,這跟大家講
所以我們來看一下
真的是你滿幸福
我不知道陳戰斗國會講的都事實
那我要講的是說以後很多人被取代
你就你要趕快撐著的時候
趕快來好不好
你是歸你失業保險
失業保險不是等政府失業保險
自己投資好不好
來自己投資好不好
歡迎中美金一樣
細金圓還是會需求很大
好不好
不好意思有時候花開兩張面中摸摸一下
也是真的很神奇
好不好
來
大家都喜歡聽一些哲哲的事情
哲哲我可以穿上一下
是啊
來
看哲演型就知道他不是缺錢看節目了
有沒有賺都沒差啦
好
我那種開心啊
好不好
來
來 八千人的
你們真的是
你們真的是 來來來
大家一起來講郭慕斯你好
你們怎麼樣
你們都犯
覺得犯罪了
覺得做錯事
哲哲我罪哲哲我下跌了
他找我
我已經跟你講了費半分,納斯拉克金33%
美國股市沒有泡沫的危機
是費半的也沒有什麼泡沫危機
新商店暫停的
我是以國際為中心點的
告訴你來華興可以買
合身檯也可以買,新商店也可以買
我也可以買什麼?
合身檯、新商店
就算我買,也不是全部買
不夠我塞牙縫
所以你不用懷疑我會不會跟誰配合
我都買大型股
你乾脆說我買台積電跟主力配合
跟位置加配合
金德奇考驗
我買什麼股票金德奇考驗
好不好
這跟大家講
來
車子的寶貝謝謝你們
維印怎麼看
滑板電我剛才說滑板電很不錯
滑板電我覺得唯一的問題是你要設停損
因為如果他跌下去會很快
好不好
滑星哥不錯
滑星哥我喜歡的
滑星哥
被動員金還會上去的
好不好
下跌都算身
來
你們先考我速度一大堆股票
優先買環境環境不錯
好不好,訊息,海力士宣佈回購股票,什麼時候的新聞來,查一下,
只能什麼時候發現自己對股市有天分呢?
大概做股票半年後,就開始都在賺錢,就認真做,
其實我實際上大概做股票大概做了快30年,
可是那時候是定存比較久,
後來就認真做股票的時候,
就是真的有操作,也就是放一檔股票,就放很久,
要不然真的有認真操作後
大概一年後就覺得蠻有天分的
好不好
來
不一定有天分 其實我跟你講
你就是傻傻的 你買台灣50
傻傻的 你買雞油股去分散
基本上你都贏了90%的賞物了
其他賞物沒有賺那麼錢
沒有賺錢或沒有賺那麼多錢
這其實是我送你情人節的禮物
其他賞物你都沒有賺那麼多錢
最大的問題是他們撐不下去
所以你不要用融資你就撐得下去
第一階條件不要用融資 不要用單充
你單充可以 就用我可能講的名言
我沒有說賭不好 但你不能騙自己在投資
單充就是賭 單充是賭絕對不是投資
你不要看那些網紅那樣 我單充多少錢
都在回忽扯了啦 單充能賺錢 我跟你講 殘疾投資更會賺錢
好不好? 但一定有少數中天分中的天分
可是當你問我你單身會不會賺錢的時候
你就不是那種人了 基本上已經不適合了
記我邏輯 這種東西還要問我的話 好不好?
來 看你買零零五零五的
也買入了隔天間展廷 我往內賺很多
這隻寶貝 請問大膽回答夠了沒
還是會繼續下探 我跟你講
我沒辦法跟你講這東西
就像我那時候知道台股會跌貨10萬點
我真的不知道
你們聽懂嗎
台股那時候會跌破10萬點 我真的不知道
你們懂意思嗎
可是我只知道台股跌破10萬點 我就是用你買
可是那現在你說台灣股市會不會回答
像幾分呢
像台灣股市會回答 我不知道會不會回答
可是我跟你講這邊現在很多股票
來大盤在這邊嘛對不對
國劇在這邊,中美金在這邊,有些回那邊的深的股票可以買,
因為基本上不會破這個,我只能跟你講,這個理論上4萬點應該不會破,
不會破的機率很高,就是有4萬點不會再來的機率很高,
居然4萬點不會再回來的機率很高,萬般拉回就是要買,
其實我給你一個結論
下半年了 你要記著一件事情
這種時間走上五窮六決七戰掉
通常會發生古宅 記起來
通常會發生古宅 最晚最晚
記起來我是
會發生古宅最晚最晚
這個也是有時間走的 沒有分析跟你講這個
這是我30年的記憶
最晚最晚是89月
8月就差不多了
9月很少古宅
好不好
你說2007、2008年
今天海嘯跌到11月21日,不要刪除3萬9
可是他股災是從5月開始
要發生股災通常8月差不多了
8月還沒有發生股災年底
Safe
年底就很安全,他等不到
我都告訴你時間走了
所以我有時候你問我問題
越繳越絕有道理
因為我涵蓋很多,比如時間走,基於現行
籌碼面,AI投資,AI的規模
還有美債的發行規模,那個要很多的參數
今天講的有點亂,但是今天非談專業
不會亂,因為真的要操作很多東西
ok嗎?接著八九月,一盤整300點,你講一講,你拉起來
要結束了
你看到現在我還給大家做生意
群年要買
群年188
逆轉188,今天結束了,今晚要10點結束了
不論對我做的一些預告前面,我看我什麼股票沒講
我們應該就講股票好了
被動元件我還蠻看好的 好不好
今天拉回有買被動元件
你可以買其他的
逆轉一發專案 今天晚上10點截止
頭女友 我最愛的就是你們
情人節有 沒有你們
不論男生女生沒有你們
今天也謝謝大家
希望你們很現實
只有議題的時候
有大題的時候才看我節目
但是我還是很愛你們
我最愛的是你們 好不好
只要你們愛我 我都愛你們
逆轉一發專案
今天晚上情人節就好
專案 今天晚上10點截止
要不參加都沒關係 我愛你們好不好
歡迎來下期0806的八點八
或假如來私訊我
不論一切的一切
只能通通預告在前面
去想想看
你要的美食
也預祝各位能夠賺大錢
前陣子快樂
我愛你們 掰掰